everybody under 15. come here
[Music]
hey everybody we are live streaming on
the rumble on the locals and the YouTube
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it's June 14th 2023 we've got a post
game show as always for subscribers if
you'd like to join us at
reubenreport.locals.com we take some
extra questions some comments some
corrections and such and uh Brock one
more time if I'm not mistaken we will be
doing some sort of promo for annual
subscribers tomorrow including free
giveaways and much more today's program
will be a continuation of some of the
things we've been hitting lately
obviously some woke stuff obviously some
genitals being chopped off obviously the
elderly man with dementia pretending to
be president and some other stuff but
really it's couched around some rather
strange comments uh Yesterday by Mark
Cuban you guys know Mark Cuban he's a
tech billionaire he's one of the sharks
on Shark Tank uh and he's kinda gone
woke or not kinda he pretty much is woke
and he's pushing woke in some of his
businesses including the Dallas
Mavericks the NBA team uh that he owns
and what's interesting about that it's
not so interesting that a major business
guy or a major Tech guy is going woke
like that happens obviously way too much
but one of the guys that he sits just
two or three seats away from usually on
Shark Tank is Kevin O'Leary and we've
played a bunch of clips of Kevin O'Leary
you might know him as Mr Wonderful on
Shark Tank uh where he has gone
completely anti-woke and the reason I
wanted to show you clips from both of
these guys and talk a little bit about
what they're doing is because uh I have
come to the conclusion that freedom
you're not going to believe this one
guys freedom is the answer
when you have worksters and
anti-worksters freedom is the answer
freedom is actually the answer to all
authoritarian uh movements capitalism
and the ability to spend money in
certain places that are in line with
your values or not spend money buying
Bud Light or go on a Target
etc etc possibly going to a Dallas
Mavericks game whatever it might be that
gives you the power that is the beauty
of freedom and we better exercise it
while we still have the ability to use
it in the United States of America as it
does seem like it's hanging on by a
tenuous thread before we get to all of
that let me talk to you guys about
Enviro cleanse guys if all home air
purifiers are the same then why did the
U.S Department of Defense select Enviro
cleanse to protect and purify air on
board our Navy ships why is it used in
thousands of classrooms across the
country well here's a couple reasons why
Enviro cleanses air purifiers have
patented Earth mineral technology and a
hospital grade HEPA filter they also
destroy cold and flu viruses covid
allergy inflaming toxins mold and even
more so here's Enviro cleanse's promise
to you they guarantee you'll experience
far fewer colds and allergies coupled
with a better sleep at night don't
believe them they'll send you a free air
quality monitor to test the difference
in your home visit ekpure.com use code
Dave for 10 off your Enviro cleanse home
air purification unit and free air
quality monitor plus fast free shipping
that's 100 in savings that's ekpure.com
code Dave ekpure.com code Dave and now
back to me I don't know if you can see
this on my shirt today but these are
little sailboats little sailboats on my
shirt maybe we'll go sailing after the
show today you know what I mean a little
Reuben report team building exercise
you're going to be on the starboard side
and what's the other side
Port thank you okay he's going to be on
the and then you know something with a
rope it's going to be a whole thing all
right let's start with this Mark Cuban
guy uh here is a tweet from myth
informed think showing you a little bit
of what Mark Cuban has been up to the
first is a headline from Fortune
Magazine Shark Tank billionaire Mark
Cuban backs Bud Light over transgender
controversy it's good business that's
the quote and then what you're seeing on
the other side of that is a tweet from
the Dallas Mavericks Mark Cuban is the
owner of the NBA professional basketball
team the Dallas Mavericks spread love
happy pride month and they've got the
rainbow flag and all the stuff in there
there's the trans flag etc etc as you
guys know I have said this many times
when when they are showing you this flag
whether this flag is hanging on the
White House whether it is hanging
outside the prime minister's office in
Canada whether it's all over every
freaking governmental building in
Brussels and everywhere that the EU has
an outpost and everything else you must
understand that the trans Flag
represents a political ideology not a
sexuality a sexuality doesn't really
need a flag okay nobody cares oh you're
a dude and you're married to a dude okay
good luck enjoy have fun but this is
something very different which is why
they are taking down flags that actually
do represent something the Canadian Flag
represents something the American Flag
represents freedom and individual
liberty and equality
the trans Flag represents Equity the
trans flag actually represents racism if
you think about it because for many
years the gays use the regular rainbow
right the old-fashioned rainbow you know
what happened yesterday we were walking
with the kids yesterday you know it
rains a lot in Florida just randomly
you'll get like 20 minutes of rain on a
beautiful day suddenly all hell breaks
loose there was a beautiful beautiful
rainbow yesterday just down the block
and I was going to take a picture of it
and post it and then I thought people
will hate me if I put up the rainbow you
see these people have ruined the rainbow
there's no pot of gold at the end of the
rainbow there used to be there you know
what there used to be there used to be a
leprechaun at the end of the rainbow now
there is some weirdo trans drag queen
twerking in front of a child okay that's
what there is now anyway
the rainbow has been destroyed but when
they put the colors so they have the
original Rainbow and then they put the
trans colors the brown and the triangle
and blah blah and then they made it
racial they made it racial because they
want this all obviously to be about
Equity when they have lined you up in
your Collective boxes you're a black
lesbian you're a Latino gay guy so
you're a little bit lower than her
you're both above the white gay guy
we'll throw a white lesbian she's a
little bit lower than the white it's all
idiotic you got it but Mark Cuban is
going in on this nonsense it's it's
really hard to believe here's a quote
from Fox News in an interview with the
Pittsburgh Post-Gazette on Sunday the
Dallas Mavericks owner spoke about the
ongoing backlash against companies like
Anheuser-Busch and the target
Corporation for promoting lgbtq plus
ideologies in their brands since
promoting what many consider woke
agendas both companies have suffered
massive losses worth billions of dollars
while experts and Industry insiders have
suggested that invoking politics led to
the downturn Cuban insisted that
embracing wokeness is a positive trait
there is a reason almost all the top 10
market cap companies in the U.S can be
considered woke it's good business he
said Cuba explained most CEOs have
enough experience to know just to wait
out the news cycle until they go to the
next one I have to say I I am completely
Mark Cuban sometimes he kind of gets it
sometimes he doesn't I've had some
exchanges with him perfectly fine on
Twitter over the years I think we've
emailed once or twice about some
business ideas like so I don't want to
make this about attacking the guy
himself but he seems extremely confused
about something here because by going
woke these con yes there was a period
where all the companies went woke right
and you open you turned on PlayStation
and it was showing you a black lives
matter logo or they were literally
giving you I remember this I don't even
use PlayStation that much but at the
beginning of covet when we're all
trapped at home I was like I'm gonna
play Playstation with my 12 year old
cousin across the country and they they
gave us a free BLM like well I don't
even know what you call like a wallpaper
so that you could have the big black
fist staring at you when you open up
your PlayStation right all these
companies went woke the question is is
it doing good or bad for the companies
if you ask Disney as they've watched
their Market uh share collapse I assume
Disney would say bad if you asked
Anheuser-Busch it's not only Bud Light
it's several of their other beers now
and the market value has gone down again
billions of dollars as he referenced
Target now billions of dollars like
we're seeing this all over this there
was a real pushback all of the woke
movies that are coming out are
struggling what was the big movie of
last year it was Top Gun it was
basically the the only movie that was
non-woke so it's a little bizarre that
Mark Cuban doesn't see that but
and I think this might be really where
it's coming from with Mark Cuban you
know these giant corporations have
signed on to ESG these ideas that we're
going to push certain social agendas
into the lives of people through Banking
and through corporate pressure etc etc
so he may just be protecting his ass
right he has many many businesses and he
may be just signaling to the powers that
be oh don't worry I'm still woke so uh
you don't have to worry my guys are all
going to have ESG we're going to have
diversity equity and inclusion
departments and everything else of
course Mark Cuban is a billionaire white
straight guy so I assume his head will
be on the chopping block soon enough but
in any event okay maybe he's just off on
this a little bit let's jump to the guy
who sits two or three chairs away from
him over on Shark Tank Uh Kevin O'Leary
Mr Wonderful we played this clip for you
a couple weeks ago and just listened to
how Stark the difference between what I
just read you from Mark Cuban and what
Kevin O'Leary is talking about right
here
well Bud Light has become the poster boy
for brand mismanagement from multiple
perspectives so let me lay it out for
you because these the discussions that
have risen and the narrative that's
risen around Bud Light is probably a
good lesson for every CEO in every
sector of the economy number one it
highlights the power of social media
this this issue went viral in 48 hours
yeah and most often when an issue goes
viral like that it burns out in another
48 hours but that's not what happened
here the story and narrative change to
sales and so people that did not like
the message regardless of where you
stand on these social issues or gender
narrative or whatever
they took it out by basically boycotting
the product immediately yeah and
switching preference to other brands
that did not make them get involved in
this issue now if you're trying to
manage that and trying to learn
something from it and I certainly talked
to all my CEOs about this because
here we are talking about it in its
second month yeah this is a nightmare
from hell for the brand so when you go
into gender narrative on a beer which is
primarily consumed by men maybe you
should have thought a little bit about
that in reading that room maybe you
should say well does this really fit my
consumer's psyche I don't know how much
commentary I have to add to that I mean
you just have to think for yourself
which one of those guys is making more
sense on this which one seems more legit
on this Kevin O'Leary clearly lays out
Bud Light beer it was for men why go and
change the demographic you're going for
and try to involve trans people in this
women men whatever you want to call them
blah blah blah Target with the tucking
stuff like you are going against your
core base now it's funny uh just a
second ago I was kind of joking it was
true but years ago when I fired up
PlayStation during covid and I'm playing
Gauntlet with my 12 year old nephew in
New York online they were showing BLM
fists and all this stuff Connor just
said to me do we have a screenshot of it
of what's going on on Playstation right
now he just took this screenshot so this
is like when you open up playstation.com
or when you open it yeah so if you go to
playstation.com right now what does that
say there great
lgbtqi plus games
what the hell is the
lgbtqi Plus game why would gay people
need different video games what would
that be even
like gay Super Mario Brothers like
Mario's like Luigi what are you doing
over there to Bowser that was pretty
good Mario come on that was right off
the top no why are you doing that to him
you're supposed to jump over him
um anyway the point is they're jamming
this stuff Luigi they're jamming the
stuffing down her throat
look all right guys who else is telling
us to cool off on the woke uh well there
are prominent politicians too and that's
why you have to watch out for this some
of them are even Republican politicians
we'll get to that in just a sec but I
want to talk to you about all the garden
pet company
that I'm going to voice the next Mario I
like it guys let's talk about olgar pet
company for a sec don't all dog food
companies want the best do all dog food
companies want the best for your dog no
not really pet food companies are
pushing trendy ingredients and expensive
recipes like fresh and raw but are they
better No in fact most of them have
proven health benefits for your dog also
watch as these dog food companies
release bug and vegan recipes it'll show
you where their priorities really are if
you don't want to compromise on high
quality ingredients and want
science-backed recipes real proven
science not fouchy science get Old Guard
it's the only pet food company founded
and run by a PhD in pet nutrition
with quality ingredients like real
chicken egg fish oil and probiotics old
guards recipes are perfectly balanced
with guaranteed health benefits and a
taste your dog will love Clyde is loving
this stuff everything including their
resealable bags are made right here in
the United States so go over to
oldguardpetco.com subscribe today and
get it delivered right to your door
using Code day for a discount with Old
Guard you don't have to compromise
ingredient quality your dog's health or
your traditional American values buy
from a company that puts your dog first
and now back to me so all right who else
is uh fighting seemingly on the wrong
side of this woke issue right so Kevin
O'Leary is fighting on the right side
and it's not even it's not even that I
think he cares about the gender stuff or
that he cares about the race stuff that
much like he cares about making money
the guy just loves money right Mr
Wonderful he loves money he loves his
little deals where he buys a portion of
your company and he gets a licensing fee
that's what he loves and in the Quest
for go going for money and capitalism
and all of those things he wants to do
what's best for the consumer which
because ultimately that will bring them
back it's best for the company the
shareholders the owner etc etc
Mark Cuban is taking a different
approach but it's not just Mark Cuban
this is a really wild uh little clip
that we're going to show you right now
Paul Ryan was on CBS News the other day
now Paul Ryan at one time if you
remember about a decade ago you know
when Mitt Romney ran for president Paul
Ryan was his VP Paul Ryan was thought to
be the future of the Republican party it
was really this limited government low
tax situation he was very much out of
the sort of Iran School of thinking and
he's often discussed how The
Fountainhead and books like that from
Iran were really his formative things
there's a lot of things about Paul Ryan
in terms of small limited government
individual rights that make sense but
one of the things that's been
interesting about the the lore of Paul
Ryan over the last couple years is as
he's gotten out of politics and and
largely become irrelevant the only
reason he's been dragged back in in many
ways is because Donald Trump who over
the years we've shown you the video has
lauded him as wonderful and what a great
friend and everything else has repeat
goodly said that Ron DeSantis is good
buddies with Paul Ryan and that Paul
Ryan's taking advice or that Ron
DeSantis is taking advice from Paul Ryan
it's simply not true we have the video
from a week or two ago where Ron
DeSantis said he's only spoke to Paul
Ryan once in his entire life and I think
it wasn't even since he's been Governor
anyway Paul Ryan was on CBS News pushing
back against Republicans who are
fighting the woke this is rather
confusing take a look
can I get your thoughts on that movement
just quickly I know we have to go but
Republican lawmakers around the country
are pushing legislation when it comes to
Banning books it could be trans rights
call it anti-walker however you want to
label it is that a good approach a good
strategy or football fan is that the way
you should approach yeah I'm not a
cultural guy I think it's really
polarizing look on some of these issues
outside uh you know with the anti-wolf
crowd but to me I'm worried about a debt
crisis I'm worried about you know the
future of our country and and China
they're a big policy problems that we
need to tackle if we want to have a
great 21st century for this country
um my work at AEI Notre Dame and my
poverty Foundation is all about poverty
and upper Mobility you know what I worry
about are the big policy challenges that
are going unresolved or made worse by
Joe Biden so that's why I want to win
this election so we can actually fix
these big policy problems cultural War
politics is good primary election
politics it's very divisive but it's
effective politics it's effective
politics I'll grant you that but for me
I'm an old Jack Kemp guy I believe in
inclusive aspirational politics solve
problems we got we get huge problems
yeah so we're going to debt crisis we've
got to get on top of this neither Biden
or Trump are good on this issue guys you
got to understand he sounds old and
irrelevant and sort of flaccid and
that's exactly why they're putting him
on CBS News as a republican first off
the host there uh the young fellow I
don't know his name uh he talked about
how Republicans are Banning books and
going after trans rights again
Republicans are not Banning books if you
want to see what the one book that has
been banned in Florida from certain
school districts and it's up to the
school district it's called this book is
gay and it literally teaches young
children how to have gay sex if you
think that that should be in a school an
elementary school then the problem
really is you certainly not Ron DeSantis
or the school administrators or any
parent who doesn't want their kid to
read about that you may remember that at
one point Ron DeSantis was giving a
press conference about the book itself
and he opened up the book and showed it
to the cameras and local news had to cut
away because they're not allowed to show
sex at 12 in the afternoon okay so maybe
it shouldn't be being in school but he
says he said something else there that I
think really captures it I'm not a
culture War guy
I'm not a culture War guy isn't that
interesting because the culture war is
coming for you whether you like it or
not doesn't he understand that Paul Ryan
the culture war is coming for your kids
I don't know if you're I assume your
kids go to private school and it's
probably a pretty elite private school
but your neighbor's kids probably go to
a public school and if wokism is being
taught there and your kids happen to
your your neighbor's kids happen to be
white or they happen to be straight and
they're taught that they're bad because
they're white or they're not actually
straight or their genitals don't match
it's like sitting out the culture War
doesn't mean the culture War doesn't
exist so he's completely wrong it's good
for primary politics but I care about
China you can do two things at once
right you can walk and carry a glass of
water at the same time like it's such
weak pathetic flaccid politics that I
think people are sick of it's by the way
it's why people like Donald Trump
because he's fought this stuff it's why
people like Ron DeSantis it's why you're
no longer in politics
but the point is he then gets on CBS to
to push this stuff because he's a what
do I call it it's always a republican oh
you'll say exactly what you oh don't
really fight against the crazy Democrats
and all that stuff no no you get a
cookie you get a cookie uh Kiera Davis
who's been on the show once or twice on
panels over the years I had a nice tweet
about that she retweeted the clip we
just showed you she wrote the I'm not a
culture War guy strategy is exactly how
we got into this mess in the first place
you don't get to say you're above the
war while you're sitting right in the
middle of the battlefield on National
Television a significant cultural front
please Sashay Away Paul and she's
totally right and again you just have to
understand how these shows operate you
have a host there who lied about
anti-trans laws and book Bannings and
everything else nobody addresses that
right like like it wouldn't the
principled position had been if Paul
Ryan was principled the principled
position would have been uh actually
could you tell me what before I get into
it I'm not much of a cult culture War
guy myself you know I'm above the
culture War I'm into low taxes but could
you just tell me what books have been
banned could you could you maybe show me
one or could you tell me what right has
been taken away from a trans person oh
that hasn't really happened like he
knows that but he's there to behave that
is how the freaking thing works uh it
was nice to see this clip this is from
Fox News Marco Rubio who's my Senator
right here and I've done some events
with Senator Rubio I like him a lot
we've had him on the show a bunch of
times but he doesn't get much National
Fanfare these days I think he's kind of
laying he's been laying a little bit low
for for one reason or another
um but he did get on Fox and I think he
made a a completely clear and cogent
point about what is going on here you
know we showed you the video from two or
three days ago at the White House they
had this dude who is in women's body
plastic boobs and the whole thing
running around topless and Marco Ruby
addressed that and connected it to some
other things happening in the world
right now
we can we can undertake a cultural
hysteria a ridiculous cultural hysteria
that plays out we had a lady or a man
that now claims to be a lady you know
going topless at the White House two
days ago at about a Pride Celebration
thing I mean we can do whatever we want
to be as decadent as we want in our
society and our culture we can break our
politics we can take our institution and
weaponize them for political purposes on
both sides we're decadent and we're in
decline because we are we thought we
could do anything we wanted with our
economy we could center jobs and
factories overseas break our politics
break our culture break our society we
don't need parents we don't need a
neighborhood we don't need family
anymore all these crazy ideas and now
reality is catching up and it's hurting
us badly and today is frankly just a
symptom of a much bigger problem we
should talk about here and that is we no
longer live in that he's right we
thought we could do anything we want
right and he's connecting that to we
thought we could do anything wrong we
thought boys could be girls we thought
we could do anything we want we thought
we could print money endlessly we
thought we could do anything we want we
could have military adventures all over
the world now reality is setting in and
we're looking around and going boy
people are depressed boy our economy is
crashing boy we're in wars that make no
sense we've got dudes in chick outfits
showing their tits
did we just get demonetized can you say
tits I should have said boobs I should
boobs is not going to get you
demonetized tits it's 50 50. anyway it
doesn't matter what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do
um the point of all of this guys is that
some people want to fight and the people
that want to fight whether they're Ron
DeSantis whether they're Kevin O'Leary
whether in this case they're Marco Rubio
whether it's you or me like we must
fight together and then there'll be a
whole bunch of people who will kind of
just wave the flag even though they're
not insane like I'm not like Mark Cuban
is not a crazy whacked out Lefty right
Paul Ryan is not a crazy whacked out
Lefty but they will just wave the flag
and we have to say no no you're no
longer helping we have to treat them we
actually should treat them the way the
mainstream media treats them oh you can
come on our shows and we'll pet you on
the head and give you a cookie and
that's it but but you are not helping us
fight you are actually not doing
anything about this call I'm not a
culture War guy really because the
barbarians are at the gate they're about
to break down the door and you're
debating what gender pronouns they are
this is a problem this is a problem so
the point is guys if we don't fight
against this woke culture and this this
never-ending lunacy it will keep
spreading and guess what it is
continually spreading uh there was a
question at the White House press
conference yesterday cringe Jean-Pierre
at the podium she was asked about the
pride flag hanging at the White House if
that violates U.S flag code
there's been some criticism also of um
the White House the flag placement the
pride flag violating the U.S flag code
did anybody notice that or or Phil
noticed that or was it a an intentional
statement you just explain what happened
so the administration was proud again uh
to display uh the pride uh flag it was a
historic event at the White House it's
centered around the love around love and
family and I think that's important and
uh so you know we're not going to to let
anyone distract us from that what was
the meaning of the day what was the the
meaning of having families here and to
celebrate a community I'm certainly not
going to get into protocols from here or
I'll leave that to others and so uh you
know we're proud of this historic event
that we were able to put together here
on the south lawn for families and so
I'll leave it there I'm telling you guys
I really admire her ability to just say
words with no meaning and that
kamala-esque sort of way she says it's
about love and family okay but that
doesn't address whether it was a
violation of the flag code which
actually is a law uh and she says I'm
not going to get into protocols up here
well then what the high hell are you
doing I'm not going to get into protocol
I'm not going to answer questions up
here who do you think I am the White
House Press Secretary let's show the the
image from the White House what you're
seeing there is the radical leftist
communist trans flag in between so it is
centered in between the two American
flags uh there's several uh pieces to
the U.S flag code but one of them is
that the United States flag is supposed
to be in the center so yes it was a
violation of the U.S flag code you may
not think that's a big deal or anything
else but when she's asked directly about
that in and of itself she can it's about
it's about love and families and all of
it I wonder how many of those drag
queens have really functional families
I'd love to know I'd really love to know
the guy who's a girl running around with
his boobs out there does he have a
family like what I it's so insane it's
so insane but it continued uh etwns Owen
Jensen asked cringe Jean-Pierre what she
thinks about guys competing in women's
sports
what would the president say to parents
out there who have daughters let's say
in high school for example who are
worried that their daughter may have to
compete against a male or a person born
male and then there could be directly in
physical athletic competition and worry
about their daughter's safety so look
and gender kids are dangerous it sounds
like that's what you're saying well
you're saying you should you're saying
that their safety is that is is at risk
yeah but you're you're laying out a
broad kind of broad example or
explanation of what could potentially
happen a broad a broad example explained
that is dangerous that is a dangerous
thing to say that essentially
transgender kids we're talking about are
dangerous and so that's something that I
have to call out and that is that is
that is that is irresponsive
she's
hold on I want you all to think about
what she is I'm going to pause for five
seconds here I'm gonna think about a
couple things couple Choice words for
her I already said tits so we're screwed
today anyway I could probably just go
ahead and do it you hear five seconds
think of a couple adjectives for
glad a good one it wasn't the one you're
thinking but it was a good one
um
look trans kids a boy who pretends he's
a girl and then wrestles a 15 year old
girl to the ground and crushes her and
breaks her skull this is a problem
Leah Thomas who is a dude with a penis
which he uses as a propeller to beat
girls in swimming is a problem the trans
movement is radically anti-girl it is
radically anti-gay because most of the
boys that are transitioning are probably
just gay boys and most of the girls who
are transitioning are probably just gay
girls and some of them are neither of
those
these people are never going to stop
they ha even the way that the that was
CBS News the headline that you saw on
the bottom and it was about anti-trans
legislation again there is no anti-trans
legislation there is legislation to stop
mutilating children and I as I said
yesterday I'm fairly certain if there
was a massive mainstream Movement by
white Christians to generally to
mutilate the genitals of children I'm
fairly certain all these people would be
against it
you got it it's just absolutely
ridiculous I'm not kidding I I may throw
on a wig and a dress little lipstick
we've got some around here somewhere and
I'm going to join the WNBA I am 40 I'm
going to be 47 in 10 days okay I am will
be a 47 year old dude with a torn ACL in
my left knee I wear three braces I put
the ace bandage I got a sleeve and the
the metal thing and I'm gonna get out
there and I'm gonna be the the NBA the
WNBA MVP
I know I could score a double digits for
sure in a WNBA game I can still shoot I
got a finger roll
you know it's all there finger all
lesbians anyway it gets crazier people
uh in California we mentioned this the
other day they literally and I mean this
literally they literally want to pass
legislation that if you as a parent do
not affirm the gender identity of your
child say your seven-year-old who comes
home and he's a boy but he likes Barbie
and he suddenly says he's a girl uh they
might let the state take your child away
yes this is real here is California
representative Laurie Wilson pushing
ab957 which if Republicans and the rest
of us were smart right when they called
hb15578 don't say gay we should be
calling ab957 Democrats are
lunatics bill
that's another one that would be
possible but anyway listen to her in her
own words on what they want to do to
these kids
so this particular
factor that affirming a child's gender
identity is in their best interest which
is what your question is about why does
it get why does it actually say that in
an affirmative way and it really is
because if you have a seven-year-old
who's who's talking about having a
potential to say I being able to
articulate that they believe that they
are not the same gender as they are
biologically then it should be affirmed
and through care it should be determined
and that's what we did with our own
child and that would give the ability
for a parent who wasn't sure to affirm
and get their child the care that they
need to make that so they can begin to
articulate that determination but by
saying and rejecting it in wholesale
then you're essentially rejecting your
child and that is not in the best
interest of a child we should be
affirming our children in every possible
way and getting them whatever
appropriate care they need whether it's
based on their gender whether it's based
on how their studies are in school it
doesn't matter our children should be
affirmed and this is saying that you
have to include gender affirmation as a
part of
lady who the hell do you think you are
you think that if someone else's
seven-year-old child is a little
confused about their gender that somehow
the government should be allowed to come
in and take their child away from them
and then mutilate their genitals you are
an effing lunatic all of you people are
lunatics and if you are watching this
and you live in California and you have
small children you must leave and if you
do not
one day they're going to come knocking
on your door for one reason or another
they'll have already taken all your
money you'll have meth addicts out in
the in your front yard you the whole
freaking place will be on fire but maybe
you will wake up when they literally
take your child away from you they never
stop and they are not going to stop
there that line each should be affirmed
she said just like my child so shocker
shocker her child is trans her child is
trans and now she wants everyone else's
child to be trans you know Jordan
Peterson talks about this a lot what
we're seeing really it's not a outbreak
of trans children it's an outbreak of
middle-aged basically mentally
compromised women like her they usually
happen to be white women she happens to
be black I don't really care about the
racial element of it but a bunch of sort
of spiritually devoid 30 let's say 25 to
you know child rearing age 45 year old
women who are want to be liked so badly
that they'll chop their kids genitals
off and then push that other people
should do it too it's absolutely insane
but the next version of all of this that
we are going to see more and more of and
we've seen quite a bit of it already is
that the more anti-woke you go the more
that you push against this say
especially in an effective way so which
is why there's been so many attacks on
DeSantis right nobody's been more
effective at fighting this stuff than
him the more that you do it the more
they will try to de-platform you all
together so this is sort of like Trump
they've removed him from all the Social
Media stuff but watch what happened
yesterday so as you know Trump was
arraigned here in Miami yesterday at
this federal courthouse and uh CNN was
covering it I saw this so to speak here
is Democrat activist Jake Tapper and he
had far left lunatic AOC on As Trump was
coming out after the arraignment and
giving a speech and listen to the way
they frame this
we um we do have now some of the sound
as I told you we're not in the audience
we're not carrying his remarks live
because frankly he says a lot of things
uh that are not true and sometimes
potentially danger yeah look at CNN
they're so principled these guys they're
not going to show anything that's not
true they're not just going to let the
president speak in his own words without
selectively editing it that's what it's
really about right because they don't
have a problem talking about Trump all
day long remember that clip from like
two weeks ago somebody somebody actually
counted and it was like from 8 A.M to 3
P.M they mentioned Trump 440 times so
they have no problem talking about Trump
they have no problem selectively editing
videos of trump but they can't just put
Trump up there to speak because he might
say something not true now of course the
irony of this is that he's sitting
across from AOC and it took us negative
seven seconds to find something untrue
that AOC did remember this during the
Jesse smilet hoax this is what she wrote
there is no such thing as racially
charged this attack was not possibly
homophobic it was a racist and
homophobic attack if you don't like what
is happening to our country then work to
change it it's no one's job to water
down or sugarcoat the rise of hate
crimes and what she was quote tweeting
there was breaking Jesse Smollett has
been hospitalized in Chicago after a
possible homophobic and racially charged
attack everything she said there was a
complete lie the whole thing turned out
to be a hoax it wasn't just her that
pushed that hoax it was everyone on CNN
including Jake Tapper it was Kamala
Harris it was Nancy Pelosi it was Chuck
Schumer et cetera et cetera Jake Tapper
who's also lied about everything from
kovid and Russia hoax etc etc it's like
the irony it's it's not even irony the
gall it's the gall that these people
have we can't show Donald Trump unedited
he might say something untrue we're
supposed to be the people saying
something untrue
but it ain't just happening with CNN and
Jake Tapper here is the televised mental
institution of MSNBC with Rachel Maddow
and she also she's not gonna have it we
can't spread misinformation on MSNBC
I need to say that former president
Trump has just started uh making public
remarks just as he did on the evening of
his first arraignment on criminal
charges that was April when he was
booked on 34 felony counts brought by
the state of New York now tonight after
his arraignment on federal felony
charges he's speaking again this time to
an audience of his supporters that's
gathered for a campaign fundraiser
tonight at his his golf club and summer
home in New Jersey
um we knew heading into this that he was
planning to make these remarks we are
prepared for his pre-fundraiser remarks
tonight to again be essentially a trump
campaign speech
because of that we do not intend to
carry these remarks live
um as we have said before in these
circumstances
there is a cost to us as a news
organization to knowingly broadcast
untrue things we are here to bring you
the news it hurts our ability to do that
if we live broadcast what we fully
expect in advance to be a Litany of lies
and false accusations no matter who says
them guys guys no matter who says them
there is a cost to them broadcasting on
MSNBC untrue things
the vaccine being able excuse me it
means for instead of the virus being
able to hop from person to person to
person to person spreading and spreading
sickening some of them but not all of
them and the ones that it doesn't stick
and don't know they have it and then
they give it to even more people because
they didn't recognize they were
right instead of the virus being able to
hop from person to person to person
potentially mutating and becoming more
virulent and drug resistant along the
way now we know that the vaccines work
well enough that the virus stops with
every vaccinated person
a vaccinated person gets exposed to the
virus
the virus does not infect them the virus
cannot then use that person to go
anywhere else
it cannot use a vaccinated person as a
host to go get more people
that means the vaccines will get us to
the end of this
everything she just said there was a
complete lie note at the exact same time
that that was happening I did not lie
about it I did not make up anything
about it I did not push anyone to get
vaccinated or anything else she
completely lied so she's okay with lies
and she did not get punished for that
lie and know it at MSNBC or CNN or the
CDC or anywhere else the NIH was fired
over their lies right Anthony fauci
retired with his 400 plus k a year
retirement package highest paid guy in
the federal government they lie and lie
and lie but I have to say uh it's not
often that I say something nice about
the people at MSNBC but they made my job
so easy today
she made my job so easy today can we
send her a fruit basket one of those
nice fruit arrangements you know what
I'm talking about where they the whole
fruit thing it looks like flowers but
it's actually fruit
yeah Edible Arrangements thank you
that's what we're going to send her
today yeah with a giant syringe in there
we're not going to tell you what's in
the syringe anyway guys the point is the
mainstream media they will they will
de-platform the dissidents of woke they
will lie about the people who are
fighting back against it and they will
also uh slander
uh the people that are fighting this
nonsense let's do one more with Rachel
Maddow since we're sending her this
delicious Edible Arrangements later
today uh here she is comparing me you
and the rest of us to 1930s fascists
see it aftermath of their successful
version of January 6 when the center
left government was blocked from taking
power they put in this pro-fascist body
and said there was another really
interesting reaction in the sort of just
the first few years after that happened
which is that all of the people on the
left and all the people in the center
who had had all sorts of differences
with each other who were always fighting
each other like cats and dogs finally
realized like oh wait actually there's
an authoritarian fascist threat that
wants to destroy all of us let's put
aside our differences form a big
anti-fascist coalition government where
we everything else that this that we
disagree on is less important than us
standing against Fascism and that's
standing for democracy and they do and
that that sense of perspective they got
from that brush with Democratic death
um is also I think something that
resonates I mean it's something to think
about in terms of what the effect is of
rising authoritarian and pro-fascist
movements in democracies are around the
world including guys when you think
about Rising authoritarianism you know
what I would call Rising
authoritarianism when the government
knocks on your door and says we're
taking your kid because your kid is a
dude even though her name is Rachel that
seems a little authoritarianism to me
okay authoritarianism would be locking
people in their homes it would be
shutting down people's bank accounts it
would be forcing people to be injected
with things and then telling them it's
good for them even though you have no
clue you are the fascist lady
you people are all the fascists you work
at a giant organization NBC news that
pays you to lie and defend the
government right so that is a
corporation and the government like this
that's the f word that's Fascism and yet
you have the gall again gall's the word
of the day here you have the gall to
call the people who are saying oh we
believe in individual rights we believe
in reality in biology we just want low
taxes and stay out of our life and
please leave us alone and yeah you're a
freak but could you just do it on your
side of the fence oh no actually
speaking of fences could we also have a
border so we actually have a country and
you're calling those people the fascists
foreign
people
they will come for you they will
de-platform you they will lie about you
and it's not just corporate press and
the and the political establishment that
will do it of course it is Big Tech and
it is big business as you know one of
the other interesting things related to
Big Tech the last couple days is this
started a few weeks ago you may remember
uh when the daily wire guys they put out
Matt Walsh's documentary it's called
what is a woman and it was framed as
this anti-trans diatribe and Matt Walsh
wants to stop the trans people all it
was was literally Matt Walsh wandering
around and talking to experts and
regular people and just ask them to say
what a woman is and people could not do
it it's quite a good movie uh because of
that they've been getting a whole bunch
of strikes across their channels on
YouTube and more we've got a bit from
the daily wire right here daily wires
co-ceo Jeremy boring called out YouTube
in a Twitter thread on Sunday revealing
a series of violations leveled against
his companies shows that he cast as a
betrayal of the video platform stated
commitment to open debate in just the
last 90 days boring said accounts
associated with the daily wire have
received 104 violations for hateful and
derogatory content mainly directed at
commentary around transgender issues
there have been more than 200 violations
in the past few months he added
penalties include Walsh being
demonetized last month Owens and Knowles
being suspended for seven days after
receiving a second strike and Peterson
Jordan Peterson getting his first strike
three strikes in 90 days and an account
gets deleted boring noted during
discussions with YouTube boring said the
video platform's policy team claims they
want to be a place where we can debate
the issue but virtually every time we
discuss it we receive these violations
yet we are on the verge of losing access
to the platform boring warrant so what's
interesting about the without getting
too under the hood on on YouTube's
policies related to all of this Brock
correct me from wrong or Connor if you
get one strike you can still live stream
or is one strike and you're out on the
live streaming
okay so for one strike you can't live
stream for a week so they put you in the
penalty box for a week if you get two
two strikes live stream at all you
cannot live stream at all and three
three strikes and your channel is just
blown up all together
do you see ladies and gentlemen why I
started locals.com and why we merged
with Rumble and why I hope most of you
are watching this live stream on Rumble
right now I'm very happy to report that
well our numbers across the board have
been unbelievable like they're just
growing and growing and growing but I'm
always particularly happy when I see the
rumble numbers growing and the locals
numbers growing because that is our
future whether it is because I said tits
instead of boobs or I called Leah Thomas
a guy or or just any of the things I
can't sit here and do a show that I do
99 off the top of my head constantly
being worried about pronouns and and the
rest of the policing especially because
we know that the people doing the
policing whether it came to election
engineering questions or whether it came
to the coveted stuff and vaccines and
lockdowns and masks and now all the
gender stuff they're on the wrong side
of everything and they lie about
everything Rumble if you're a Creator
out there whatever you do you're a
politics guy you're a you're a freaking
unboxer you're a gamer whatever they
will not threaten to strike it don't
break the laws of the United States
you're good to go on Rumble so anyway
that's a little commercial for that but
people have had it people really have
had it and again there is pushback and
that's why I keep encouraging you guys
whatever you can do in your life to push
back a little bit more it starts
bubbling up and other people start
pushing back here's a really beautiful
video by Megan Kelly now Megan Kelly who
you know I adore Megyn Kelly obviously
and we've done many shows together over
the years and everything else uh Megan
Kelly not only talks the talk but she
walks the walk Megan Kelly lived in New
York City during covid and all of the
woke lunacy that we have experienced
over the last couple years her kids
school went insanely well pushing the
gender stuff on all on her children she
has three three relatively young
children and she got up and left she did
what I did I moved across the country
she left the state of New York and she
has just had it with not only the
walksters but the big tech people who
were in cahoots with them to silence us
I dare you I dare you to de-platform me
Apple I Dare You I Will Rain hell down
on you for a woman speaking up for girls
and for her fellow women and our rights
to be safe and to have our spaces I dare
you I will unleash hell on that company
I will actually lead protests in the
street I will go to the outside of Apple
headquarters they cannot do it they
can't they will live to I will make them
a Bud Light if they try to shut down
these conversations because we are
finding our voices and we're getting
help from men right Matt Walsh has been
amazing all the guys at Daily wire and
so many others and the the audience I
mean people are figuring it out right
now after girl after girl gets hurt
woman after woman gets hurt loses money
loses safety loses something so I don't
think that they're that they can do that
I really don't I don't she means it she
means it I know Megan well enough she's
not just saying it she will do it so
that is the challenge if you're if
you're a YouTube employee and you're why
watching this right now and you're not
happy because I said this or that or
because we've titled our videos one way
or another or everything else you know
one of the things is and and one of the
reasons that I'm always encouraging you
guys to move over to rumble is because
the more of you that move over to rumble
the less important YouTube will be right
like that's the key part of this every
people are like well why do you do
anything on YouTube then and it's like
well there's still there is still a
discovery element of YouTube it just is
but I want to make sure that if today if
today was the day and don't think it
couldn't happen remember they remember
they took Trump off all the platforms on
one day so don't think it couldn't
happen don't think the powers that be
uh couldn't just all sit down in a room
and say you know what today's the day
let's take out the daily wire Channel on
YouTube let's take out Reuben let's take
out Megan Kelly let's take out Crowder
and let's take out you know five other
people let's just take them all out
bongino's already gone from YouTube
altogether right so it could happen at
any moment and that's literally why I
started local so please even if you
don't want to throw a couple dollars in
if you want to just join so that we can
always directly contact you because I
can send push notifications out to you
reubenreport.locals.com it's absolutely
free to join and be part of the
community if you want to engage a little
bit more it's a couple bucks a month
anyway that that's not that but the
point is there there are alternatives
and we have to just we have to keep
finding the Alternatives and again it's
Alternatives whether it's alternative
Tech platforms or if it's alternative
schools for your kids or if it's
alternative states that you have to live
in if they are coming to your door or
plan to come to your door and again your
son is now a girl and the state's going
to take him away you got to move you got
to find an alternative and we have that
in America so right to bring it right
home from where we started full circle
what did I say freedom is the answer to
all of this stuff
Mark Cuban has one feeling on woke Kevin
O'Leary has another obviously I agree
with Kevin O'Leary but they're both
exercising their freedom in America and
the market will decide who is Right
YouTube is exercising its feelings
rumbles exercising its feelings you
whether you still live in Cali or you've
moved to Florida are exercising your
feelings the experiment is going on and
that is a freaking beautiful thing I
think we have one more quote actually
from Mark Cuban that Phoenix has given
me on the Fly here uh this is from Cuban
himself most CEOs have enough experience
to know uh to just wait out the news
cycle until they go to the next one
since Bud light's apparent partnership
with transgender influencer Dylan
Mulvaney was revealed in April the
company has seen a 23 percent nine
decrease in sales on a dollar basis
compared to a year ago now I'm reading
the article obviously Fox Business also
reported that Anheuser-Busch owned
Brands sales fell by 25 Point uh 24.5
percent in the past four weeks alone the
Target Corporations market cap also lost
billions of dollars since the company
began displaying the lgbtq plus and
pride month advertisements and products
including tuck friendly women's
swimsuits they're not women's swimsuits
they're men's swimsuits on Friday Fox
Business reported that Target stock fell
by roughly 3.1 percent and within the
last five days and approximately 18.5
percent in the last month so that's it
guys that really is it the proof is in
the pudding there are other places to
buy bathing suits than Target there are
other beers to buy than Bud Light there
are other companies to support that are
aren't owned by Mark Cuban and there's
other basketball teams to like other
than the Dallas Mavericks and everything
else you have a chance to fix this it
will help uncensor us it will help right
the ship
and God damn it I'm going to write this
ship
uh wait I was going to go into Mario
voice so please and join us we're gonna
be on the poster gamer show oh it's a
Reuben a
reporter.locosa.com who would be there
in about 30 seconds we'll leave you with
the call to close Luigi what are you
doing to Bowser
upholding the rule of law means applying
the law evenly without fear or favor
under my watch that is precisely what
the justice department is doing
[Music]